ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES BACKER
PORCHES BRADFORD BY ADAM CORTES
HE SALLY DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
WESO HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN
HOTEL OF BOTH PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN NUMBER
WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER WELL.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WHAT OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE REAL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE. WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER TODAY BY SENATOR COM
LONGER AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
AND WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR DORADO.
CENTER CALLED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS WE CELEBRATE BLACK
HISTORY IN A PARTICULAR WAY THIS
MONTH. MAY OUR DREAMS BE DREAMS
OF LANGSTON HUGHES AS EXPRESSED
THROUGH EXCERPTS IN HIS POEM I
DREAM A WORLD. I DREAM A WORLD
WHERE ALL WILL KNOW SWEET
FREEDOM'S WAY. WHERE GREED NO
LONGER SAPS THE SOUL NOR AVARICE
BLIGHTS OUR DAY. I'D WORLD I
DREAM WHERE BLACK OR WHITE
WHATEVER RACE YOU BE. WILL SHARE
THE BOUNTY OF THE EARTH AND
EVERYONE IS FREE. WHERE
WRETCHEDNESS WILL HANG ITS HEAD
ENJOY LIKE A PEARL ATTENDS THE
NEEDS OF ALL MANKIND OF SUCH A
DREAM MY WORLD. YOUR ABUNDANCE
GOD OF GRACE MOTHER OF HOPE IN
THIS MONTH OF REMEMBRANCE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE AND EMBRACE THE
POWER AND CREATIVITY THAT OUR
BLACK SISTERS AND BROTHERS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED FOR THE GROWTH OF
THIS NATION. CONTINUE TO WIDEN
OUR VISION SO THAT TOGETHER WE
MAY BRING OUR WORLD CLOSER TO
HARMONY AND PEACE COMMUNION AND
SOLIDARITY AMEN. COLLEAGUES JOIN
ME AS WE HONOR OUR COUNTRY THAT
STANDS FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THANK YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVED
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG SOONER YOU PREPARED
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
TAKE YOUR SEATS IN- DOWN ON THE
CHATTER THANK YOU. SENATOR
HERTZBERG FLOOR'S YOURS. EVERY
TIME. THIS IS. YEAH. A BAND. SO. MEMBERS IT IS. WITH DEEP DEEP
SADNESS THAT ARISE. IN MEMORY OF
ONE OF OUR OWN. A MEMBER OF THIS
TEAM RESPECTED BODY. WE SAT
RIGHT OVER THERE IN IRAQ TO
SITTING. PASSED AWAY HE WAS A
FRIEND OF MINE AND A FRIEND OF
SO MANY IN THIS ROOM TODAY. AND
A COURAGEOUS LEADER. OF OUR
STATE NAME SENATOR GARY K. HEART
. CENTER HEART PASSED AWAY. ON
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH AFTER A
HARD FOUGHT BATTLE WITH
PANCREATIC CANCER. WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE HIS WIFE KERRY
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS UP IN THE
GALLERY WITH US TODAY. ARM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE WE'RE
ALSO FORTUNATE TO HAVE ONE OF
GARY'S LONG TIME STAFFERS
PHYLLIS CHAU WITH US PHYLLIS
WORKED WITH GARY FOR OVER TWELVE
YEARS. IN THE SENATE. ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE HER AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THEY CAN'T SEE IT
THURMOND TOLDMAYBE SOME OTHER
STAFFERS WHO WORK WITH HIM OVER
THE YEARS. HERE TO CELEBRATE
CENTER. GREAT LEGACY I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING. WITH
SENATOR HART AND GETTING TO KNOW
HIM. HERE IN THIS CHAMBER AND ON
THE BOARD OF THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA WE SERVE
TOGETHER. I SAW FIRST HAND IS
LEGISLATOR AND- AS IT AT THE PP
I SEE WHAT AN EXTRAORDINARY
STUDENT TO PUBLIC POLICY HE WAS
. AND I CAN SAY WITHOUT A DOUBT
MEMBERS THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM SENATOR HART'S DEVOTION. AN
EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. HIS CAREER HIS
CAREER BEGAN IN A CLASSROOM
WHERE HE TAUGHT HIGH SCHOOL
GOVERNMENT. HOW FITTING. HE
BROUGHT THAT EXPERIENCE WITH HIM
AS HE COMMITTED HIMSELF TO
BETTERING OUR STATE'S EDUCATION
SYSTEM. SENATOR HART WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR AND SERVED
THERE UNTIL NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. HIS
SERVICE IN THE LEGISLATURE SPAN
THREE GOVERNORS. GOVERNOR BROWN
COLORED MEIJIN GOVERNOR WILSON
DURING A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA
WAS MORE PURPLE IT IS POLITICS
TWO OF THE THREE GOVERNORS HE
SERVED WITH. REPUBLICANS HE'S
PERHAPS BEST KNOWN FOR HIS WORK
IN TRANSFORMING CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS. IS WORK TO REDUCE CLASS
SIZE IMPROVE TEACHER QUALITY AND
ESTABLISH GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. LANDMARK
LEGISLATION IN NINETEEN EIGHT TO
ESTABLISH CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA PAVING THE WAY FOR
THIRTEEN HUNDRED CHARTER
CAMPUSES WE SEE ACROSS THE STATE
TODAY. AND THEY COLLECTIVELY
SERVE ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. BUDGET CATION WAS A
PASSION HE ALSO ADVANCED
EXTRAORDINARY LEGISLATION ON
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES IN
WOMEN'S RIGHTS. GEHRY CREATED
SOLAR TAX CREDIT THAT HELPED
CALIFORNIA BECOME A WORLDWIDE
LEADER IN SOLAR INNOVATION
ADOPTION WHILE ALSO FURTHERING
ENVIRONMENTAL AND COASTAL
PROTECTIONS. HE ALSO PASSED A
LAW TO INCREASE CHILD SUPPORT
FOR DIVORCED WOMEN. THAT IS JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG WHAT
SENATOR HART DID HERE IN THIS
CHAMBER AND IN THE OTHER HOUSE
DURING HIS TIME HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THERE ARE FEW
WHO CAN CLAIM SO MANY FAR
REACHING POLICY SUCCESSES. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW AFTER HE SERVED
IN THE LEGISLATURE HE EVENTUALLY
WENT ON TO BECOME THE EDUCATION
SECRETARY. TO GOVERNOR GRAY
DAVIS THE GOVERNOR'S FIRST
APPOINTMENT WHEN ELECTED
GOVERNOR. WELL SECRETARY SENATOR
HART. HELPED IMPLEMENT THE
STATE'S FIRST HIGH SCHOOL EXIT
EXAM ENSURE A GRADUATING SENIORS
POSSESS THE RIGHT SKILLS NO
MATTER WHAT SCHOOL THEY
ATTENDED. MEMBERS WE THINK ABOUT
THE GREATS THE GREATS. WHO ONCE
STOOD WHERE WE STAND TODAY WE
MUST THINK. OF LEADERS LIKE
SENATOR HART. SENATOR HART WAS
SUCH A PRINCIPLE PERSON AND YOU
GAIN RESPECT FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE GOVERNOR DAVIS
RECENTLY SAID THAT HE COULD NOT
RECALL A SINGLE PERSON IN
SACRAMENTO WHO EVER SAID A
CRITICAL WORD ABOUT GARY AND I
THINK THAT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE
AND I HAVE THE SAME RECOLLECTION
. YOU ALWAYS KNEW WHERE GEHRY
STUDENT ISSUES MOST LEGISLATORS
HELD A DEEP RESPECT FOR HIM
BECAUSE HIS ACTIONS WERE ALWAYS
MOTIVATED. BUT WHAT HE THOUGHT
WAS RIGHT THING TO DO. IT SHOULD
BE THAT MUCH OF HIS LEGISLATIVE
SUCCESS. TO BE ABLE TO CLOSELY
WORK WITH MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES AND IMPORTANTLY. HE
DEDICATES DEDICATED LOYAL STAFF
AGAIN. THEY SAID EARLIER HE
LEAVES HIS WIFE GARY HART WAS
HERE TODAY. HE TRICIA KAISER.
WITH THREE DAUGHTERS ALYSSA
KATHERINE AND LAURA. JERRY WAS A
RIGHT PUBLIC SERVANT WHO REALLY
WANTED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. AND
HE MOST CERTAINLY DID MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN WITH ME IN A TURNING
IN THE MEMORY OF CENTER GARY K.
HEART A LEADER AMONG LEADERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG CENTER LAMONT. THANK
YOU MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
HONOR THE FORMER SENATOR GARY
HART FROM THE CENTRAL COAST. AS
LEADERS WE OFTEN LOOK AT WHO
STEPS WE ARE FOLLOWING. WHAT
DOES BEFORE US HAVE DONE. GARY
HART IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THOSE
LEADERS WHO STEPS PRECEDED MINE
. AS ONE OF THE SENATORS WHO HAS
FOLLOWED HIS REPRESENTATION OF
THE CENTRAL COAST I AM HONORED
TO RECOGNIZE HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WELL HE SERVED IN THE
LEGISLATURE. GERRY'S COMMITMENT
TO SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTIES SET CHANGES IN MOTION
FOR MANY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
WHICH I CAN PROUDLY SAY WE HAVE
pHIS WORK TO STRENGTHEN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM. OUR EDUCATORS
AND STUDENTS ALL AROUND
UNDERSTOOD HIS IMPACT. WHETHER
IT WAS FUNDING FOR K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND HIGHER EDUCATION
CLASS SIZE TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OR HIS LEGISLATION
CREATING A PATH FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE. CAREY'S
DEDICATION IN SACRAMENTO HAS
INFLUENCED MILLIONS OF LIVES OF
CAL IN CALIFORNIA. HIS PASSION
FOR EDUCATION IS HOW HE
CHAMPIONED EFFORTS THAT THAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY CHANNEL ISLANDS
CAMERI- IN THE DISTRICT. YES
UCI. HAS NOW SEEN OVER TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS GRADUATE
SINCE THE UNIVERSITY ACCEPTED
ITS FIRST CLASS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWO. THANKS TO THE WORK DONE. HI
GERRY AND OTHERS. AS THE CURRENT
SENATOR FOR THE TO CENTRAL COAST
COUNTIES WORK TO PROTECT COASTAL
AXIS IN THE ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT GEHRY
PRIORITIZED IN OUR COMMUNITY
PROTECTING OUR COAST ESPECIALLY
FROM OFFSHORE OIL PROJECTS. IN
ADDITION WE CANNOT OVERLOOK HIS
LEGISLATION CREATING THE SOLAR
TAX CREDIT. AS I READ SEVERAL
PIECES ABOUT GARY IN THE
DISTRICT FOLLOWING THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF HIS PASSING IT
WAS EVIDENT THAT HE WAS HIGHLY
RESPECTED. I REMEMBER GETTING
INTO OFFICE AND MEETING WITH
GARY IN MY OFFICE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO YOU JUST TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT
HE HAD WHILE IN SACRAMENTO BUT
THAT REFLECTED THE VOICES IN THE
LIVES OF THE CENTRAL COAST. HIS
CHARACTER LEAD TO POLICY CHANGES
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF OUR ENTIRE
STATE. ALTHOUGH HE WAS A BRIEF
MEETING IT WAS A GLIMPSE OF HIS
PERSONALITY. AND WHAT HE BROUGHT
TO THE CAPITAL WHEN HE
REPRESENTED SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA COUNTIES FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS WHEN YOU TALK TO PEOPLE IN
THE DISTRICT THE ONE A COMMON
WORD THEY USE TO DESCRIBE GARY.
IS INTEGRITY. I AM HUMBLED TO
FOLLOW IN HIS WORK AND JOIN THE
SENATE TODAY TO ADJOURN AND THE
MEMORY OF SENATOR GARY HART.
THANK YOU CENTER TOMORROW
SENATOR NELSON. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THAT.
STRIKES ME IS. CHALLENGING THE
OTHER DAY WHEN I GOT WORD OF THE
PASSING OF SENATOR HART IT WAS
KIND OF LIKE. THAT CAN'T HAPPEN
. HE WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE HERE
. I PRAYED AND PONDERED ABOUT
THAT AND I REALIZED THAT. YOUR
HEART ALWAYS WILL BE HERE. AB
ONE OF THE SENATE. SOME OF THE
VERY FEW PASSED THROUGH HERE
HAVING MADE LITTLE NOTE NOR LONG
TO LEAVE TO REMEMBER. NOT SO.
WITH SENATOR GARY HART. THE TWO
GENTLEMAN. VERY STEEPED IN THE
TRADITIONS OF THIS INSTITUTION
RESPECTFUL OF THOSE INSTITUTIONS
AND A GREAT EXAMPLE. AND I DO
HOPE THAT HE BE REMEMBERED HERE
FOR THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS THE
INTEGRITY OF THIS INSTITUTION.
GARY HAD A NATURAL AFFINITY AS
AN EDUCATOR. TO BE AN EXPERT IN
EDUCATION. BUT AS OF KNOWLEDGE
HERE HE HAD MANY OTHER AREAS
THAT HE CARED ABOUT. MY SPECIAL
MOST PERSONAL TIME WAS WORKING
WITH HE VERY HARD. AND JOHN
VASCONCELOS I'M DOING A NEW
MASTER PLAN FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE MISSION GOALS
INTERRELATIONSHIPS OF THE THREE
LEVELS OF HIGHER EDUCATION. ONE
OF MY GREAT MEMENTOS. IT IS. A
PICTURE OF A HOUSE COMMITTEE
ROOM WITH THOSE OF US WHO WERE A
PART OF THAT CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE. GARY AND JOHN.
SITTING AROUND THE TABLE SIGNING
THE CONFERENCE REPORT THE PUT
THAT INTO EFFECT. AS WE SIGNED
AND MUSED ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTION
. I THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT A LEGACY
THAT MASTER PLAN HERE'S- NOT WAS
. THAT IS. KNOWING AT THE TIME
THAT THAT EFFORT. WOULD GO ON
THROUGH THE GENERATIONS AND
THOUSANDS MILLIONS. BY IT WOULD
NEVER KNOW. ANYTHING OF THOSE TO
HELP MAKE THAT SO. GARY ALSO WAS
COURAGEOUS. CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE
NEVER BEEN. A HIGH POINT OF
SYMPATHY WITH SOME IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION. BUT GEHRY AS A
RECOGNIZED LEADER. THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION EMBRACED THE ROLE OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THE QUALITY
OF EDUCATION. NOT AS A
COMPETITOR BUT AS A COMPLIMENT.
THAT IS PIONEERING LEGISLATION.
LIVES ON THIS DAY. ONCE UPON A
TIME WE USED TO DO A LOT OF
INTRUM HEARINGS. AND THAT'S ONE
THOSE FEW OF US ON THOSE
ENTERING COMMITTEES. GOT TO
SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF. ONE ON
ONE TIME WITH EACH OTHER. AND
THEN EVENING HAVING DINNER.
AFTER HERE. AND I REMEMBER MANY
SUCH OCCASIONS WITH GARY BECAUSE
I DID A NUMBER OF THINGS IN
EDUCATION AS WELL AND OTHER
AREAS WERE AND WE SERVE. A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEES. HE'S A
PROBLEM SOLVER. NEVER
CONFRONTATION THE FIRM AND HIS
CONVICTION. AN ADAMANT ABOUT
WHAT HE BELIEVED IN AND
ADVOCATED FOR. ALL I CAN SAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS I SPEAK
HERE WITH A BIT OF A HEAVY HEART
. I'M ALSO REJOICE. FOR THIS IS
REALLY AN OCCASION FOR
CELEBRATION. NOT MONNING THE
MORNING AND MORNING BUT OF
CELEBRATE. A LIFE WELL LIVED.
CONTRIBUTIONS WELL MAY. AND THEY
WILL LIVE ON SUCH WILL BE THE
LEGACY. GARY HART. OUR HEARTS GO
OUT TO HIS FAMILY. WILL THE
HORROR HARBOR FOR FUNDAMENTAL
MEMORIES AND WE CAN EVER HOPE TO
ENJOY. BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS MAN
LIVES ON. AND OUR HEARTS AND IN
THIS INSTITUTION BUT HE MADE
SUCH GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO. GOD
BLESS YOUR VERY HEART MAY BE
WITH THE LORD. I THINK SOONER
NIELSEN SENATOR ON BURKE. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES- THIRTY TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN I CAME TO THE ASSEMBLY
I GOT A CALL NOT LONG AFTER I
WAS HERE THAT THE SENDER GARY
HART ONE TO HAVE BREAKFAST WITH
ME. AND I THOUGHT WHY IS UNITED
STATES SENATOR GARY HART
PRESIDENTIAL ASPIRANT WANTED
BREAKFAST WITH ME I THIRTY THREE
YEAR OLD ASSEMBLY PERSON BUT TO
MY GREAT GOOD FORTUNE. IT WAS
SENATOR GARY K. HEART. AND WENT
TO BREAKFAST. AND FROM THAT
POINT FORWARD I BECAME A HUGE
ADMIRER OF CENTER HEARTY CHAIRED
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE I
SAT. ON THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND HIS VISION HIS
INTELLECT HIS RESPECT FOR THE
INSTITUTION TO RESPECT FOR ALL
WHO SERVED IN THE INSTITUTION.
HIS GENTLE BUT- VERY PERSUASIVE
METHOD OF ADVOCACY. WAS MOST
EFFECTIVE HE WAS THEN WHAT I
ASPIRED TO BE AS A LEGISLATOR IN
WHAT I ASPIRE TO BE NOW AS A
LEGISLATOR MAYBE WHAT WE ALL
SHOULD ASPIRE TO BE. SOMEONE WHO
. TOOK VERY SERIOUSLY HIS ROLE.
AS A STEWARD OF CALIFORNIA. AND
DID A MAGNIFICENT JOB BOTH AS A-
AS AN EXAMPLE. N. AS A SERVANT
OF CALIFORNIA AND I JOIN ALL OF
YOU IN A TURNING IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I TO- WAS TO RISE A
TURN IN MEMORY OF CENTERS JERRY
CAPEHART AND- WELL HE REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL COAST HE CERTAINLY
HAD A HUGE IMPACT HERE MY
DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
TWO THOUSAND AND THREE MISTER
HART ESTABLISH THE PACE PROGRAM
AT SACRAMENTO'S JOHN F. KENNEDY
HIGH SCHOOL. AND PLACES A
SUCCESSFUL HONORS HUMANITIES
PROGRAMS THAT ENCOURAGE STUDENTS
TO BE CIVICALLY ENGAGED IN FACT
MORE IN TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS
SEPARATE GRADUATE FROM THE
PROGRAM. INCLUDING MY VERY OWN
LEDGER LEGSLATIVE DIRECTOR WAS
ABLE TO EXPERIENCE THE THRILL OF
THIS. BUILDING THROUGH THE PACES
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM. YOU CONTINUE
TO INSPIRE STUDENTS WITH THE
STORIES AND EXPERIENCES AS HE
TAUGHT GOVERNMENT CLASSES AT SAC
STATE. AND THE CENTER HEART WAS
ALWAYS KNOWN FOR KEEPING AN EYE
ON HIS STUDENTS WHO WOULD WRITE
PERSONAL LETTERS TO THEM TO
CONGRATULATE THEM UNDER
COMPLIMENTS. INSPIRED
GENERATIONS AND HIS LEGACY WILL
CONTINUE VOTED MOTIVATE MANY
GENERATIONS TO COME. I TO WANT
TO GIVE MY PERSONAL CONDOLENCES
AND SYMPATHIES TO HIS WIFE CAREY
HART WHO IS A COLLEAGUE OF MINE
IN PEDIATRICS. AND GEN I WISH TO
EXPRESS MY SYMPATHIES. AND NOW I
CAN'T HEAR FROM DOWN HERE THE
GALLERY BUT I WANT AGAIN EXPRESS
MY SYMPATHIES. ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT HIS FAMILY IS WELL. AGAIN I
WISH THE ALSO THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF SECRETARY PART THANK
YOU. THINKCENTRE FAN CENTER
STERN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE IN THIS. OF COURSE ACROSS
THE ISLAND MANY GENERATIONS
LEADERSHIP IN MEMORY OF. GARY
HART- I WAS AT ANOTHER ONE OF
THOSE BREAKFASTS I DON'T KNOW IF
IT WAS THE SAME YEAR IS- MY
SENATE COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE
COUNTY BUT- THIRTY THREE YEARS
OLD AS WELL. AND JUST GETTING
STARTED PUBLIC SERVICE. AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE LOOKING AT ME LIKE
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE KIDS.
NOW IT'S NOT YOUR TIME YET AND-
YOU GOTTA WAIT. END WHEN I SAT
DOWN TO BREAKFAST WITH GARY HART
IT WASN'T ABOUT ANY OF ANY OF
THE POLITICS OR ANY OF THE
POMPEY WAS JUST SUBSTANCE HE
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IN OPEN SPACE IN
ASSURING ME I WAS COMING IN AND
THIS IS PART OF A DISTRICT THAT
. PEOPLE SAID WELL I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'RE REALLY GOING TO BE ON
BOARD WITH AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ATTORNEY OR WITH. SOMEBODY WHO
CARES ABOUT ISSUES OF JUSTICE-
IT'S YOU GOT TO GO EASY ON THAT
STUFF YOU SHOULDN'T YOU KNOW
YOUR IN YOUR ANY SPRINTER A
COUNTY YOU'VE SEAMY VALLEY. YOU
YOU REPRESENT YOU KNOW THE
NORTHWESTERN PART OF LA AND- BUT
THAT WASN'T HIS ADVICE HIS
ADVICES. PEOPLE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY GOOD. IT DIDN'T
MATTER WHERE I REPRESENTED I CAN
JUST BE MYSELF. AND TO MOVE OUR
AREAS I MEAN FROM SANTA BARBARA
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO VENTURA
COUNTY IN LA AND- NOT SHAPE
SHIFTING BE THE SAME PERSON
EVERYWHERE YOU WENT- THAT WAS A
SPECIAL THING TO BE EXPOSED TO
IT- VERY EARLY PART OF MY CAREER
AND VERY FORMATIVE AND SO. I
MEMBER WE HAD PANCAKES I WAS
VERY IMPRESSED. HE THE ENTIRE
PLATE- WITH A MAN WHO NOT LEFT
THIS BUILDING EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
GONE AND- THAT KIND OF LEGACY TO
ME. IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY TO
APPROACH A JOB LIKE OURS. THAT
YOU CAN THINK YOU'VE GOT YOUR
TIME AND THEN YOU MOVE ON. BUT
THAT. THAT THAT PART OF HIM THAT
JUST WOULDN'T LET GO OF PUBLIC
POLICY MAKING OF SERVICE I HAD
ONE MORE IDEA FOR YOU AND IN THE
COMING YEAR. HAVE YOU THOUGHT OF
THIS ARE JUST STILL GOING WITH
THE WORK THAT THAT'S THE TRUE
SIDE OF A SERVANT WHEN NO ONE'S
WATCHING. SO I I'LL I'LL MISS
HIM DEARLY. AND I WISH I HAD ONE
MORE THOSE PRACTICE BECAUSE- YOU
KNOW- THOSE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YOU JUST MISSING YOUR LIFE SO.
I'M GLAD WE'RE TAUGHT SAYING HIS
NAME TODAY AND- THE TURNING IS
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENATOR
BLASIER. THANK YOU OF MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND SHARING MY OWN
MEMORIES OF MY TIME WITH GARY
HART WAS FORTY TWO YEARS AGO
THAT I FIRST MET HIM AS A- YOUNG
IMPRESSIONABLE STUDENT LEADER
COMING TO THE CAPITOL. TO
ADVOCATE FOR OUR COMMUNITY. AND
AT THE TIME AS THE SENATOR FROM
THE NORTH MENTIONED IT WAS JOHN
VASCONCELOS INCENTER LEROY
GREENE WAS CHAIR I BELIEVE THE
SENATE EDUCATION AT THE TIME.
AND GARY HART WAS ONE OF THOSE
FOLKS WHO WAS CLEARED OF US WAS
IMPORTANT- LEADER IN THE
EDUCATION SPACE AND I NEEDED TO
GET TO GET TO KNOW. BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT STRIKES ME.
ABOUT THE FIRST MEETING AND I
AND ALL THE SUBSEQUENT
OBSERVATIONS OF HIM. THE COURSE
OF HIS LEGISLATIVE CAREER WAS
THAT. IT WAS NEVER THE
LEGISLATIVE ACHIEVEMENTS. THAT I
REMEMBER AND I KNOW THERE WERE
MANY AS HAVE BEEN SPOKEN TO
TODAY. BUT REALLY WHAT'S STUCK
OUT FOR ME AND CONTINUES TO THIS
DAY WAS THAT. HE REPRESENTED
THE- THE QUALITY OF LEADERSHIP
THE CONDUCT OF LEADERSHIP- MORE
THAN THE SUBSTANCE. HE WAS A
GOOD LISTENER HE HE WAS
THOUGHTFUL. HE SHOWED ME THE
POWER OF A SOFT VOICE AND HE HAD
A SOFT VOICE. SHOWED ME THE
IMPORTANCE OF GRACIOUSNESS. AND
SO AS YOU LOOK AT HIS CAREER AND
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT HE INFLUENCE
. HE STAFF SOME OF WHOM ARE HERE
THE INTERNS THE FELLOWS THE
STUDENTS IN HIS CLASS. HIS STYLE
AND APPROACH TO LEADERSHIP. IS
THE THING THAT I KNOW HE
INVESTED A LOT OF. IS THOUGHT TO
AND IT COMMUNICATED AND IS BEEN
EFFECTIVE T ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
FOLLOWED HIM IN THE PATH OF
GOVERNMENT OR WORLD EVER ELSE
THEY HAVE. CHOSEN TO LEAD THEIR
LIFE. HE WAS A LEADER GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENT. BUT HE WAS A
LEADER OF GREAT INTEGRITY AND
GRACE. AND HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT. HEARING AND
SEEING NINE MEMBERS WE WANT TO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. TRIBUTE TO
AN AMAZING LEADER AND SHARING
YOUR STORIES I THINK WE'LL ALL
AGREE HE EXEMPLIFIES WHAT IT
MEANT NOT ONLY TO BE A GREAT
LEGISLATOR BUT AGREED STATEMENT
AS WELL WELL THE NAMES WHERE YOU
BRING SENATOR HART'S NAME FOR IT
SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON FROM
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. MISTER
PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON THIS
DAY PASSED AS AMENDED SENATE
BILLS. ONE THIRTEEN ONE FOURTEEN
ONE FIFTEEN ONE SIXTEEN AND
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
HONORABLE BODY TO CONCURRENCE AT
AMENDMENTS TO PARKER CHEAPER FOR
THE ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILLS ORDERED
TWO UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE.
THANK YOU REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNAL FOR THE WEEK OF JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST TO FEBRUARY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE COURT. MEMBERS NOW
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILLS. 924-925-9269.
TWENTY SEVEN NINE TWENTY EIGHT
NINE TWENTY NINE NINE THIRTY
NINE THIRTY ONE AND SENATE BILL
NINE THIRTY TWO. CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FIVE
SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE. ASSEMBLY
BILLS 848-713-9140 TWO AND
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN.
NO MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WE HAVE
ITEMS ON THE SUPPLEMENT FILE WE
HAVE FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SHE IS PREPARED
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO THE
STATE BUDGET AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BELT.
SENATOR SKINNER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- SB ONE
FIFTEEN IS THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AND IT'S THE FIRST OF OUR
EARLY ACTION ITEMS ON THE
MINUTES TO THE BUDGET THAT WE
ADOPTED LAST JUNE THIS BILL
AMENDS THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET
ACT AND MOST SIGNIFICANTLY SB
ONE FIFTEEN TRANSFERS ONE POINT
NINE BILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
RELIEF FUND FOR PURPOSES RELATED
TO OUR CORPORATE NINETEEN. STATE
OF EMERGENCY. FUNDS WILL BE USED
TO INCREASE TESTING CAPACITY.
ENHANCE AND EXPAND VACCINATION
PROGRAMS BOLSTER OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SUPPORT FRONT LINE
WORKERS AND ADDRESS THE CURRENT
SURGE IN CASES BECAUSE BY THE
OMICRON PERIOD. IT ALSO
APPROPRIATES THIRTY POINT THREE
MILLION TO ASSIST IN MEETING
EMISSIONS CONTROL REQUIREMENTS
ON FOUR THIRTY MEGAWATT
GENERATORS THAT WERE PURCHASED
UNDER AN EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION
ISSUED BY THE GOVERNOR IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT
APPROPRIATES FORTY SEVEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION FOR SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FOR PRIVATE CENTER BASED
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS. REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
ALLOCATE GENERAL FUND RESOURCES
FOR CASH FLOW LOANS TO THE STATE
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR THE LOCALLY
ADMINISTERED RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE PAID BACK
UPON THE REALLOCATION OF FEDERAL
FUNDS. THAT THE STATE. IS HAS
PLAYED FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED BOTH THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
APPLIED TO THE U. S. TREASURY
FOR ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
RELOCATION DOLLARS. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS IDENTIFIED
REALLOCATION DOLLARS AND- WE ARE
HOPING TO BE FIRST IN LINE AND
THAT IS SB ONE FIFTEEN. THANK
YOU FOR THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
VEHICLE ON THE SIDE OF ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION IS RIGHT ON
THE SIDE OF SENATOR WILL. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. ALTHOUGH
THERE'S MANY GREAT THINGS IN
THIS BUDGET. BILL THERE'S SOME
THERE'S NOT SO I HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY- OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE TODAY. WHEN THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS IS EIGHTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TO
VALENCIA LABS. WHICH IS A
FACILITY IN MY DISTRICT. DURING
THE PANDEMIC GOVERNOR NWSOM
CAME TO MY DISTRICT WITH GREAT
FANFARE TO ANNOUNCE THIS NEW
VENTURE. WHICH BY THE WAY WAS A-
NO BID SINGLE SOURCE CONTRACT.
AND IT WAS GOING TO TESTING IT
WAS CAN BE MARVELOUS. WELL IT'S
BEEN A COMPLETE FIASCO. IF
THEY'RE CURRENTLY BEING
INVESTIGATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- FOR THEIR FOR THE
INCOMPETENCE AND POTENTIAL
CORRUPTION- THERE IS
INVESTIGATION DONE BY THE STATE
THE STATE HELD ONTO IT WAS DUE
IN MARCH. THEY DIDN'T RELEASE
IT. AND THEY DID RELEASE AN
IMMENSELY BUT THEY RELEASED IT
RIGHT AFTER THE- THE RECALL WAS
OVER. AND THEN WITHOUT FANFARE
HE DID AN AUTOMATIC RENEWAL OF
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
TO THIS COMPANY- THEY'RE
CHARGING PEOPLE ANYWHERE FROM
TWENTY ONE TO FIFTY DOLLARS TO
TEST. WHEN YOU CAN GET IT ON THE
OPEN MARKET FOR TWELVE DOLLARS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DASHBOARD TO
THE WORST PERFORMING TESTING
FACILITY IN THE STATE- L. A. U.
S. D. IN THE SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE'RE SO FRUSTRATED
WITH THEM THAT THEY HAVE NO THEY
NO LONGER TESTS THERE. AND I
UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC. MAYBE YOU
HAVE TO GIVE AN EXECUTIVE SOME
POWER TO BE ABLE TO MANEUVER
QUICKLY. BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
WHERE I THINK WE'VE REALLY
FALLEN DOWN ON THE JOB IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IN
TERMS OVERSIGHT. THIS IS A
FACILITY THAT SHOULD BE PROBABLY
SHUT DOWN AND TODAY WE'RE GONNA
GET ANOTHER EIGHTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN I JUST DON'T BELIEVE
IN REWARDING BAD BEHAVIOR. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I'M GONNA READ
RESPECTFULLY BE A NO VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. SO WIENER. I THANK MR
PRESIDENT ON MY RIGHT SO OF THIS
MEASURE AND SPECIFICALLY I WANT
TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP AND THE
GOVERNOR ON OUR BUDGET I CHAIR
IN SOUTH OF FOR THE WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FUND DOES NOT RUN OUT
OF MONEY- AND TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
WE ARE EXPECTING MORE FEDERAL
SUPPORT BUT WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHEN THAT'S COMING AND
SO MAKING SURE THE CASH FLOW IS
THERE AND THAT WE'RE FRONTING
THAT CASH FLOW. SO THAT RENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA- I CAN ACCESS
THOSE LIFESAVING FUNDS TO MAKE
SURE THEY CAN STAY IN THEIR
HOMES AND SO THE LANDLORDS ARE
PARTICULARLY SMALL LANDLORDS ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE FUNDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT BACK RENT THAT IS
BEING PAID IT'S HARD TO
OVERSTATE HOW CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT- THIS RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE THROUGH AND
HOPEFULLY COME OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC SO MANY RENTERS ARE AT
RISK OF LOSING THEIR HOMES SO
MANY RENTERS ARE AT RISK OF
HAVING LONG TERM CRUSHING RENT
THAT. IN SO MANY LANDLORDS ARE
REST OF FOREVER REALISTICALLY
LOSING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
THE RENT THAT THEY ARE OWED THIS
FUND IS SO IMPORTANT AND IT HAS
BEEN IT'S BEEN RUNNING OUT OF
MONEY- AND SO I'M SO GRATEFUL TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
OFFERED KEEPING IT GOING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF. IN NINE SEVEN SKINNER WHICH
ALLOW TO CLOSE. I AM YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM. ON
TWENTY NINE. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER I
PORCHES NO BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
WHAT HAS HE HI DOLLY. DODD FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
WHERE SO HYPERTONIC I JONES NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMON I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MAN HI NEWMAN. I NIELSEN NO I
TROUBLED. PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI MY CASKEY
I WIENER AYE WILK NO. THIRTY
THIRD PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
. BATES HAVE I EVER DALLY GROVE
A TROUBLED. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERTAIN
CURTIN MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY. SKINNER
SKINNER PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL ONE
FOURTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELIGIOUS THE
BUDGET. CENTER CENTER THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB ONE
FOURTEEN REESTABLISHES THE
COVERT NINETEEN SUPPLEMENTAL
PAID SICK LEAVE PROVISIONS THAT
WERE PART OF OUR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT- WE ALL ARE QUITE
AWARE OF THE SURGEON COVERED
NINETEEN CASES. AND WE ARE. THIS
ACT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT THOSE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE SICK CAN.
TAKE THE PAID SICK LEAVE THAT
THEY NEED SO THAT ALL OF US ARE
PROTECTED NONE OF US WANT TO
HAVE TO GO TO A WORKPLACE WHERE
WORKERS ARE SICK. AND OR GET
THEIR TAKE CARE OF THEIR
CHILDREN WHO MAY BE SICK. SB ONE
FOURTEEN REQUIRES EMPLOYERS WITH
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES
TO PROVIDE UP TO FORTY HOURS OF
SUPPLEMENTAL PAID SICK LEAVE. IN
ADDITION IT ENTITLES A COVERED
EMPLOYEE TO TAKE UP TO FORTY
HOURS OF THIS SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK LEAVE. IF THEY EMPLOY
THEMSELVES OR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBER. IF FIVE IS TEST POSITIVE
FOR COVERT NINETEEN AND DOES THE
EMPLOYER MUST CARE FOR THE
FAMILY MEMBERS THE BILL APPLIES
RETROACTIVELY TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND WILL
REMAIN IN EFFECT UNTIL SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO- I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR. ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT LANDED ON THIS
AND FOR WHICH WE ARE THERE'S
BEEN GOOD AGREEMENT WITH THAT
MEMBERS I ASKED HER I DON'T.
THINK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
BORDERS. GUESS WHAT. TESTING
TESTING. THIS MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME THAT WE PROVIDE THIS
LEVEL OF- SECURITY FOR EMPLOYEES
. AND WE DO IT IN A WAY THAT
LOOKS AFTER THE WHOLE OF THE
ECONOMY. MY CONCERN ABOUT THIS
THOUGH IS THAT WE'RE ASKING
THESE INDIVIDUAL ENTERPRISES TO
SHOULDER THE BILL. WE'VE GOT
ESTIMATES THAT THIRTY TO FORTY
FIVE BILLION IN SURPLUS THIS
YEAR LAST YEAR WAS SEVENTY FIVE
TO OVER A HUNDRD. IF THE
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES ARE NOT
UPPING THE ANTE TO PROVIDE THIS
LEVEL OF TAX CREDITS WITH THIS
AMOUNT OF SERVICE SHOULD WE NOT
AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROVIDED. SO ASKING SMALL
BUSINESSES TO DO SO I THINK IT'S
AN UNNECESSARY BURDEN WHEN WE
HAVE THE CAPABILITIES TO STEP IN
AND LEAD ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S AS
MERITORIOUS AS COVERT
PRECAUTIONS. BECAUSE EVERYBODY
IN THIS ROOM HAS HAD SOME DEGREE
OF EXPERIENCE WITH EITHER
CONSTITUENTS FOR DIRECT FAMILY
MEMBERS OR FRIENDS. WHO HAVE HAD
CODE OR BEEN EXPOSED TO
CORPORATE OR FORCIBLY
QUARANTINED NO ONE IS IMMUNE
FROM THIS. AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE HAVING TO GO THROUGH THE
PROTOCOLS WHETHER IT'S TEN DAYS
OR FIVE DAYS ACCORDING TO CDC.
TEND TO MISS OUT ON WORK AND NOT
GET PAID COULD BE DETRIMENTAL. I
THINK CALIFORNIA'S TO STEP UP IN
LEAD IN THIS AREA IN THIS SPACE
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES IT IS A
MATTER. UP VOTE AGAINST THIS
ITEM NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT IT DOES
BUT BECAUSE THE FUNDING SOURCES
IS IMPROPERLY PLACED. AND I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES
CALIFORNIA'S STEP UP AND DO THIS
. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING AND SEEING NINE
CENTER SKINNER TO LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I WOULD
JUST NOTE AS I INDICATED THE
OPENING THAT THIS AFFECTS ONLY
EMPLOYERS OF TWENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES OR MORE AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES. NO
BACKER. I FORGES NO BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO CORTESE I DALY DODD HI
TORONTO I FIVE PLEASE. I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI
WESA. HI- TADA I JONES NO
KAMLAGER I WHERE I LEYVA AYE MON
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN
. I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO A
CHIRLA BOTH NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN HI I'M BURKE I
WE CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE WILK NO
. THIRTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HAVE I EVER. DALLY
GROVE. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS SEVEN.
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS OR CONCURRED
IN. NON MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY ONE. SENATOR
SKINNER'S PREPARED MEANT
SIGNATURE YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO
ECONOMIC RELIEF AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
A TO ME MEDIA WE DELIVER RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SB ONE THIRTEEN IS THE ECONOMIC
RELIEF TRAILER BILL. AND AS YOU
RECALL. IN TWENTY TWENTY WHEN WE
WHEN THE PANDEMIC FIRST HIT. AND
THE STOCK MARKET INITIALLY FELL.
WE WERE NOT CLEAR WHAT HOW
REVENUES IN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
AFFECTED. AND SO WE SUSPENDED A
FEW OF OUR- A BUSINESS TAX.
PROGRAMS THE NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTIONS AND A COUPLE OF
THINGS AND WE- HAVE REALIZED OF
COURSE SINCE THAT TIME THAT OUR
REVENUES HAVE STAYED HEALTHY THE
STOCK MARKET DID BETTER THAN
EXPECTED AND SO THIS ECONOMIC
RELIEF TRAILER BILL. LIFTS A
YEAR EARLY THE SUSPENSIONS THAT
WE MADE ON THOSE TWO ON THE NET
OPERATING LOSS IN THE TAX
CREDITS REDUCE TAX PAYMENTS WE
ALSO ARE IN THIS BILL PROVIDING
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IN
ONE TIME FUNDING TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESS GRANT PROGRAM IS YOU
KNOW THAT'S BEEN VERY WELL
RECEIVED AND IS- WE HAVE MORE
APPLICANTS. THAN THE FUNDS WE
HAVE AVAILABLE SO THIS HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION WILL ENABLE US TO
FIND THE REMAINING ELIGIBLE WAIT
LISTED APPLICANTS. IT THIS BILL
ALSO CONFORM STATE TAX LAW. TO
FEDERAL TAX LAW FOR RESTAURANT
REVITALIZATION FIND AND FEDERAL
SHUTTERED VENUE OPERATORS GRANTS
AND EXCLUDES THESE GRANT
PROCEEDS SO THESE FEDERAL GRANT
PROCEEDS FROM STATE TAXABLE
INCOME IT ALSO MAKES A VARIETY
OF CHANGES RELATED TO THE
ELECTIVE PASS THROUGH ENTITY TAX
AND TAX CREDIT PROGRAM. TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
CAN FULLY DEDUCT ON THEIR
FEDERAL TAX RETURNS THE
CALIFORNIA TAXES THEY PAY ON
PASS THROUGH BUSINESS INCOME AND
FINALLY INCLUDES CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE THAT- TO ENSURE THAT
THE ASSISTANCE FOR RELIEF THAT
WAS PROVIDED. TO CUSTOMERS FOR
THEIR ARREARS ON WATER
WASTEWATER GAS AND ELECTRIC
UTILITY PAYMENTS RELATED TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS NOT
CONSIDERED AS TAX- UNDER INCOME
FOR TAX OR BENEFIT ELIGIBILITY
PURPOSES. AND WITH THAT I
ESPERANDO. THANK YOU ANY FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR HERTZBERG. BIJLI
MISTER RICHARD I JUST WANTED TO
THANK BUDGET COMMITTEE I ALSO
WANTED TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND GOVERNANCE OF FINANCE. THE
DEALT IN THE DETAILS OF SOME OF
THESE ENDEAVORS PARTICULARLY AS
IT RELATED TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FEDERAL TAX ACT WHICH
CREATED THE SALT DEDUCTION THAT
ADVERSELY AFFECTED CALIFORNIA
SIGNIFICANT WAY. AND I JUST
THINK THAT THE ATTENTION TO
DETAIL TO FIX SOME OF THOSE
MATTERS WERE QUITE IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS. TO ALLOW
THEM TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL TAX DEDUCTIONS AND- I
APPRECIATE THAT AND ASK YOUR
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THE
RIGHT. SENATOR VOTE. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT- I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE- WE MUST LIFT THE
SUSPENSION OF THE NET OPERATING
LOSS AND DEDUCTION AND THE CAP
ON BUSINESS INCENTIVE TAX
CREDITS SUCH AS THE R&D CREDIT
THAT WERE IMPOSED TO ADDRESS A
BUDGET SHORTFALL THERE REALLY
NEVER MATERIALIZED AB EIGHTY
FIVE OF TWENTY TWENTY TRIGGERED
THE SUSPENSION OF THE N. O. L.
PRODUCTION AND THEY ARE INDEED
TAX CREDIT DESPITE OPPOSITION
FROM LEGISLATIVE REPUBLICANS IN
A HUGE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
JOB CREATORS. LAST YEAR MANY OF
US CO AUTHORED AB FIVE NINETY
THREE WHICH I'D LIKE TO MENTION
WAS BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION TO
RESTORE THE L. L. AND ALREADY
CREDITS FOR CALIFORNIA'S LIFE
SCIENCES COMPANIES FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TAX YEARS THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
UNFORTUNATELY KILLED AB FIVE
NINETY THREE AGAIN WITHOUT A
VOTE MANY OF US ALSO SIGNED ON
TO BIPARTISAN LETTERS THAT LAST
YEAR CALLING FOR RESTORATION OF
THESE TAX CREDITS ON JULY FIRST
INTRODUCED AN AMENDMENT TO
RESTORE THE TAX CREDITS TO AB
ONE FIFTY ANOTHER BUDGET TRAILER
BILL DESPITE THE FACT. THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET SHORTFALL
NEVER MATERIALIZED AND WE HAD A
MAJOR SURPLUS THAT LAST YEAR MY
AMENDMENT WAS TABLED WITHOUT
DEBATE LAST YEAR I NOTED THAT WE
NEEDED TO BE INVESTING IN
PROMOTING CALIFORNIA'S
INNOVATORS INNOVATORS LIKE THOSE
IN LIFE SCIENCE INDUSTRY WHO
MADE KOBE AND KOBE NINETEEN
VACCINE A POSSIBLE INNOVATORS
LIKE THE GREEN TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY THAT ARE GOING TO BUILD
THE CARBON REDUCE WORLD THAT WE
ALL WANT. A RECENTLY RELEASED
REPORT BY THE MILKEN INSTITUTE
FOUND THAT SPENDING RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT TAX CREDIT INCREASED
COST UNCERTAINTY FOR BUSINESSES
AT A TIME WHEN ECONOMIC
VOLATILITY WITH ALREADY HIGH FOR
THREE DECADES DISINCENTIVE HAD
HELP BUSINESSES LOWER THE RISK
INHERENT. TO INVESTING IN
PRODUCT IN PROCESS IMPROVE. BUT
THE POLICY TO THE SIGNAL THE-
COMMITMENT TO INNOVATION LED
GROWTH. WHAT WE ARE HERE TODAY
AFTER TWO YEARS OF SENDING WRONG
SIGNALS TO CALIFORNIA'S
INNOVATORS AND BUSINESSES. AND
WE ARE FINALLY SENDING THE RIGHT
SIGNALS. FOR THAT I SAY THANK
YOU TO OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING A LONG HARD LOOK AT THE
PATH TO TODAY THAT ASPIRIN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION VERY
HEARING THREE NINE CENTERS CAN
YOU MAKE CALLS. THANK YOU I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. PRESS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FOLLOW
UP ITEM THIRTY ONE. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BAKER. I PORCHES AYE BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO CORTESE HI DALY
DODD HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH
. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. I FURTADO
AYE JONES FIVE KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA. I LIMON I
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ FIVE MEN HI
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN HI A TO A
BOTH HI PAM AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN AYE NUMBER NINE I LIKE HOW
SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK HI. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS WITH ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
AND- EVERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FALL ITEM THIRTY. FILE ITEM.
THIRTY TWO. FIVE SENATORS
REPAIRMAN SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACT RELATING TO HUMAN
SERVICES AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SKINNER SKINNER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SB ONE SIXTEEN IS THE HUMAN
SERVICES CLEAN UP BILL AND IT
REINSTATES PROVISIONS THAT WERE
INADVERTENTLY CHAPTER OUT BY AB
ONE SEVENTY TWO WHICH WAS THE
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER BILL WE
PASSED IN JUNE- IT ADDS
FLEXIBILITIES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN SPENDING.
THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT FUNDS AND THESE
FLEXIBILITIES WILL HELP SERVE
NEW ARRIVALS FROM AFGHANISTAN.
AND IT APPROPRIATES TWENTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SUPPLEMENTS
FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. AND
WITH THAT IASK YOUR I DON'T.
THANK YOU ANY JUST OR DEBATE ON
FALL ITEM THIRTY TWO. HEARING
THIRTEEN NINE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BECKER AYEFORGES AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO CORTESE.
DALLY DODD. HI AWESOME I EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. FIVE
RETARDER FIVE JONES. I KAMLAGER
I LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE THE MON
HI MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE UNTIL
ABOUT FIVE PM HI PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI HI QUITE
HOW SKI I WIENER AYE WILK. I THE
GROUP PLEASE CALL THE ABSOLUTE
MEMBER. HAVE I EVER PORTENDING I
. DALLY GROVE. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS IT ZERO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARE CONCURRED AND NOW TO OUR
LAST ITEM FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
INNER SCANNERS PREPARED SECTOR
YOU MAY READ SENATE BILL ONE
SEVENTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT%
RELATING TO STATE EMPLOYMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL REALLY TO THE
BUDGET. INTERSTELLAR THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB ONE
SEVENTEEN PROVIDES LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION TO DEMO YOU SIDE
LETTERS THAT THE STATE HAS
RECENTLY SIGNED WITH SIX STATE
EMPLOYEE BARGAINING UNITS IN THE
SIDE LEVERS PROVIDE EMPLOYEES
WITH A MONTHLY STIPEND TO HELP
COVER EXPENSES RELATED TO
TELEWORK EMPLOYEES DESIGNATED AS
REMOTE CENTERED WILL RECEIVE
FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH AND
EMPLOYEES DESIGNATED AS OFFICE
ENTERED WILL RECEIVE TWENTY FIVE
A MONTH. THIS BILL APPROPRIATES
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION TO ACCOUNT
FOR THIS ADDITIONAL BENEFIT
WITHOUT AYE AUSTERE AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER. OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HEARING JINAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND VOLUME THIRTY THREE. ALLEN
AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BAKER. HI FORGES I
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO QUARTET
THE I DALY DODD. FIVE TORONTO I
EGGMAN. I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA I LIMON I
ACQUIRE. HI MELENDEZ AYE MIN
FIVE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A
CHOI BOGUE I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER
AYE STERN AYE I'M BURKE HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK. I
ARE YOU THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE CONCURRED
AND NOW MEMBERS REMOVING BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS CENTER
BAR. YOU THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND EMOTIONS.
HELLO UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS BECAUSE OF THE
CONTINUING IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC IN TO ENSURE
LEGISLATIVE IN COMMITTEE
OBLIGATIONS CAN MEET ALONG WITH
A SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD HERE IN
THE SENATE THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK REQUESTING
PERMISSION TO SUSPEND ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION EIGHT OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND JOINT RULES
FIFTY FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ALLOWING SENATE BILLS.
INTRODUCED BY IN THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO BE AMENDED HEARD
AND ACTED UPON THE SENATE BEFORE
THIRTY CALENDAR DAYS HAVE
ELAPSED WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. NINETY
NINE MEN SECTOR PLEASE CALL.
ZERO READ THE RESOLUTION PUSH.
RESOLVED THAT PURSUANT TO
ARTICLE FOUR SECTION EIGHT A OF
THE CONSTITUTION ALL SENATE
BILLS INTRODUCED IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MAYBE HEARD IN
COMMITTEE AND ACTED UPON BY THE
SENATE BEFORE THIRTY CALENDAR
DAYS HAVE ELAPSED SINCE INSTR
INTRODUCTION AND THAT JOINT RULE
FIFTY FIVE BE SUSPENDED TO
PERMIT SUCH HEARING AND IT
ACTION PRIOR TO BEING AND PRINT
FOR THIRTY DAYS. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF. NINETY
NINE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. NO BACKER.
FIVE LARGEST NO BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO CORTELLI I DALY DODD
FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN FIVE
PLACER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO I HER TADO
I JONES NOPE KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA AYE THE MON. I MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ. NO MAN HI NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN NO A CHAU VOTE NO PAM
. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO
I SKINNER FIVE STERN HI I'M
BURKE I WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. HI.FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS IT SIX. JOINT ROOM THIRTY
FIVE HAS BEEN SUSPENDED. UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERMAL
INDUSTRY. FIVE SOMETHING I READ
HERE I DO THANK YOU- MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS PERCENT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I AM
AGAIN MAKING THE MOTION WOULD
DRAW AND SEE OUR FIVE FROM THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR A VOTE. PRACTICALLY
EVERY BILL RELATING TO COVE IT
HAS BEEN GIVEN A HEARING. IN
COMMITTEE AND VOTED UPON WHETHER
IT IS FAILED OR PASSED IT IS
BEEN GIVEN THE HEARING AND WE
HAVE DEBATED IT. SO I THINK THIS
BILL SHOULD NOT BE ANY DIFFERENT
IF YOU FEEL THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY SHOULD CONTINUE. THEN
YOU WOULD VOTE AGAINST THE BILL
IF YOU FEEL IT'S TIME TO END THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY. THEN YOU
WOULD VOTE FOR THE BILL BUT WE
HAVE. A SUPERBOWL COMING UP IN A
STAIUM THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW. WHETHER YOU THINK. A
STATE OF EMERGENCY SHOULD
CONTINUE WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE A SUPER BOWL GAME WITH A
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
PARTICIPATION. TAKING OFF THEIR
MASKS TO EAT AND DRINK AND CHEER
AND EVERYTHING ELSE SHOULD WE
STILL. CONTINUE THIS THERE ARE
OTHER STATES. DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS
BY THE WAY. WHO HAVE ENDED THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY MORE THAN
THIRTY STATES IMPACT IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE ENDED THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. IT'S TIME I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. CINNABAR THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE THANK YOU CINEMAGOERS US
FOR NO VOTES IN YOUR MIND
MELENDEZ IS ASKING FOR A YES
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. TO WITHDRAW ALLEN NO
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BASS I
BAKER. BAKER NO FOR JUST I
BRADFORD NO COME BY ADAM HAS HE
NO DALLY DODD. NO TORONTO NO
EGGMAN NO GLAZER NO GONZALEZ NO
GROWTH HERTZBERG. WESTERN NO HER
TADO NO JONES I KAMLAGER. NO
LAYERED NO LEYVA NO LIMÓN. NO
MCGUIRE NO MELENDEZ AYE MIN NO
NEWMAN NO NIELSEN HI A TROUBLED
HI PAM NO PORTANTINO. NO ROCK NO
RUBIO. NO SKINNER. NO STERN. ALL
RIGHT. STERN NO NUMBER NOPE BY
COUNTY. NO WIENER NO WILK YEAH.
HI. THIRTY THIRD PLEASE CALL
THAT THE MEMBER. HAVE I EVER.
DALLY GROVE HERTZBERG. MOTION TO
REDRAW. FIVE SEVEN KNOWS TWENTY
NINE THE MOTION FAILS. MEMBERS
IF THERE'SNO FURTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DEATH IS
COOLER MR PRESIDENT THANKS SO
MUCH. OUR NEXT SCHEDULED SESSION
IS FOR THIS THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT NINE
AM THANK YOU. MEMBERS THE SENATE
WILL BE RECESSED UNTIL THREE
THIRTY WHICH TIME AND
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT
NINE EIGHT AM ENJOY THE REST OF
YOUR DAY.